this cell isn't meant to hold this many
people Human Rights Watch says these
prisons are overcrowded and detainees
are Keen to tell us what they're going
through
every time I go to court the judge isn't
there if you're late the police beat you
and ask you for bribes then they tell
you to get ready how can you get ready
on time when there are three washrooms
for over a hundred people
there aren't enough bathrooms there's no
cleanliness and the food is terrible
lawyers have to speak to their clients
through bars
the main reason for overcrowding in
prisons across Pakistan is the poor
Judicial System prisoners don't have
clean water prisoners sit on cold floors
and if there's a toilet meant to be used
by 10 people it's being used by over a
hundred a normal person can't go inside
there it's so disgusting
but some are making attempts to increase
standards authorities here acknowledge
that there is an issue of overcrowding
within prisons but they say it's not a
problem for the prison system they say
the problem is with the policing and
justice system it takes considerable
time for trials to start and for
verdicts to be handed out
at this prison Festival they came to
show us their arrangement for visitors
they acknowledge the facility is holding
twice its capacity
934 is the capacity of this prison
Department under today's counting is
2019 prisoners
in the of this jail
and it is definitely overpopulated jail
we are getting constructed in the seven
multi-story Barracks for the prisoners
and it in the sooner this problem of our
population will be solved they tell us
medical staff are available for
prisoners 24 hours a day and meals have
been put together with the help of
nutritionists from the city's University
the prison is a legacy of colonialism it
was built by the British in the 19th
century
but with a country in economic and
political crisis bringing it up to 21st
century Western standards may take some
time
Al Jazeera Pakistan